hi guys
uh when i first bought windows vista i
noticed that there was um on youtube i
found that there was a built-in
show menu delay in windows vista when
you actually right click your desktop
there's a delay built in to when you
actually click
say all programs and open
uh say a folder there's actually a
built-in delay
so i'm going to show you how to get rid
of that delay you're going to open
uh your regis reg edit which is the
registry editor if you're in windows xp
you go start run and then type in reg
edit
it's in programs uic pops up hit
continue
and here is a registry editor now i've
already opened both all up so i'll show
you again
what you want to do
go into hkey current user
expand it
scroll down to control panel expand that
go down to desktop
expand it
actually don't expand desktop simply
click on it
and when you're in desktop scroll down
and you'll see a menu show delay
this is it double click on it and set
that value to one don't set it to zero
but set it to as low of a value as
you're comfortable with and this will
eliminate the delay
when clicking on a menu or expanding
something in windows vista whether
you're right clicking or in the start
menu scrolling through your programs etc
so this will eliminate your delay
i hope this helps you speed up your
windows vista browsing peace out guys